Yeomans never stop burning black smoke
billows out from mexico city's
crematorium their cremating here on an
industrial scale and the bodies don't
stop coming
they can't code there are full capacity
already the corona virus pandemic has
struck and Mexico is powerless to stop
it versus queue to deliver their cargo
of kovat 19 victims there is a three day
waiting list in full hazmat gear
crematorium workers deliver the bodies
to the huge ovens the kovat coffins are
piled up waiting to be destroyed
this is early morning and there's lots
of coffins already they're cleared each
day
Sky News has investigated this with the
help of staff we visited multiple
morgues and spoken to and visited dozens
of hospitals cemeteries than funeral
parlors the story is always the same
they can't deal with the bodies the
fridges are full the body bags are on
Gurney's waiting for collection
in an autopsy room the investigation
tables are now redundant they're
surrounded by body bags there is no room
in the rest of the hospital's morgue
facilities in this storage room the
bodies are piled on wooden pallets
workers say there are three more rooms
like this makeshift morgues a funeral
parlor worker has to pick through the
corpses to find the right body to take
away for cremation this is what it's
like there are so many dead it's hard to
keep track and in truth this is only the
beginning outside a family member asked
the hearse drivers to stop he wants to
see the body inside the coffin the
system is so overstretched he wants to
make sure he's about to cremate his
actual family member he like most people
we've spoken to here doesn't trust the
government or the system it's breaking
down people are getting angry
Carlos is waiting for his sister to
collect the cremated remains of her
husband he doesn't believe a single word
the government says notices Actos in
almost implemented many comment all
those new gary's at you not even others
see precise actors do not oversell
cuantos Moreno corpo Vito o como simmer
Iran's implement opponent be PO
the truly heartbreaking part of all of
this is outside the crematoria
some family members are allowed inside
but five is the maximum here they must
say their goodbyes her uncle has died
she had no chance to say anything to him
she couldn't say goodbye and she can't
enter the crematorium her uncle is dead
the finality is crushing
[Music]
what is staggering is a number of people
being cremated and the volume of verses
and traffic it just doesn't stop the
queues are huge it just goes on and on
Mexican government says that they
flattened the coronavirus curve and that
there's going to be a huge drop-off in
the number of deaths being recorded our
own analysis of 30 different crematoria
so that that isn't the case at all
they're all working to full capacity it
means at least 600 people a day are
dying here and you can see from these
queues that never ever stop this sort of
position that the Mexican government is
taking is and they are winning just
doesn't seem to be right the Mexico
outbreak is following the same trend
seen across the world
the upward curve of death looks set to
rocket the health service can't cope and
social distancing let alone lockdown
it's largely being ignored in Mexico
City short of a vaccine or a miracle the
effect on society from Cova at 19
it's a strong stir on to Sky News Mexico
you